el cirujano realizará una cirugía de
glaucoma para fijar problemas de drenaje
en el ojo debido a la alta presión
intraocular
la cámara anterior se llena con un
líquido acuoso llamado humor acuoso que
baña y nutre la córnea y la lente cuando
el humor acuoso fluye desde la cámara
posterior continuamente drena a través
de la red trabecular entre el iris y la
córnea el flujo adecuado del humor
acuoso mantiene la presión dentro del
ojo normalmente balanceada
cuando se produce el glaucoma el humor
acuoso drena hacia fuera demasiado lento
o es producido demasiado rápido
originando la acumulación del líquido
que incrementa la presión intraocular
con la atención de esta presión las
fibras del nervio óptico se dañan y con
el tiempo mueren lo que puede producir
la pérdida de visión permanente las
opciones de cirugía de glaucoma incluyen
los procedimientos con láser y sin láser
el procedimiento dura por lo general
entre 10 y 60 minutos
si se somete a un procedimiento el láser
se deberá sentar con el rostro mirando
hacia la máquina láser se le
administrarán gotas oftálmicas para
adormecer el ojo se colocará un pequeño
dispositivo en los ojos para mantener
los párpados abiertos
una trabeculoplastia es un procedimiento
láser que aumenta el drenaje de líquido
desde la red trabecular durante una
trabe culo plastía láser el médico usará
una lente de contacto especial sostenida
sobre el frente del ojo para enfocar un
rayo de luz láser en la red trabecular
si el procedimiento tiene éxito ello
permitirá que fluya más líquido del ojo
lo que disminuirá la presión intraocular
una árido tome a periférica es un
procedimiento láser que abre un ángulo
de drenaje estrecho o cerrado entre la
córnea y el iris este ángulo cerrado
interfiere con el drenaje del líquido en
este procedimiento
el médico utilizará el láser para
realizar un pequeño orificio en el iris
lo que permitirá que el líquido fluya
más libremente dentro del ojo
la ciclo fotocoagulación es un
procedimiento láser que reduce la
producción de humor acuoso
en la ciclo fotocoagulación el médico
usará un láser para destruir partes del
cuerpo ciliar que produce un humor
acuoso si tiene éxito reducirá la
producción de líquido y disminuirá la
presión del ojo
una trabe colectomía es una cirugía
incisión al que extrae una parte de la
red trabecular del ojo durante este
procedimiento
el médico utilizará pequeños
instrumentos para extraer diminutos
trozos de tejido de la pared del ojo
dejando un pequeño orificio a través del
cual el humor acuoso puede drenar hacia
afuera y ser re absorbido en el flujo
sanguíneo
aunque los medicamentos y los
tratamientos quirúrgicos puedan ayudar a
prevenir futuras pérdidas de visión no
pueden reparar la visión que se perdió
debido al glaucoma luego del
procedimiento usted será controlado
durante una o dos horas antes de
retirarse se le colocará un parche
ocular o vendas para usar temporalmente
se le recetara gotas oftálmicas y se le
indicará cómo utilizar las probablemente
el médico le aconseje mantener el ojo
seco durante un tiempo evitar nadar o
bañarse y dejar de manejar temporalmente
levantar peso o esforzarse